hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so in this video we're going
to talk about is how to work with the
area formula for kites and rhombi so
rhombi is just plural for rhombus right
multiple rhombus it's okay so the way we
do this is we use this formula right
here area equals one half diagonal 1
times diagonal 2 so it's a pretty easy
formula but the diagonal is this
distance from this vertex to the
opposite vertex so you can see that
whole length is diagonal 1 this whole
length is diagonal 2 of course it
doesn't matter which order okay because
multiplication is commutative and then
in a kite it's the exact same formula so
it's nice you just have to take this
whole length times this whole length
times 1/2 and that gives you the area
now just a quick refresher kites okay
they have two consecutive pairs of sides
that are congruent so you can see that
these sides are congruent and these
sides are congruent but these are not
congruent and then in aramis all four
sides are congruent and the interesting
thing to note also about kites and
rhombi okay are that the diagonals are
actually perpendicular to one another so
they form right angles here where they
cross let's look at a couple examples
you'll understand a little bit better
how this works so say like this first
one over here we want to find the area
alright so we have to take this whole
diagonal which you can see is going to
be 3 plus 8 so that's 11 so the area is
going to be 1/2 times 11 times this
diagonal now you might be saying Mario
we don't know this piece right here
right well in a kite this diagonal right
here is a line of symmetry so if you
fold the kite like this this angle
matches with this angle this matches
with this you can see this side matches
with this side it's an exact you know
it's like cut in half it's the exact
line of symmetry so you fold it over so
this 5 here is gonna be the same as this
segment length here 5 so that whole
diagonal is gonna be 10 so if we go
ahead and multiply that out 1/2 times 10
is 5 times 11 is 55 units squared and
that's the area of the triangle not the
triangle I'm sorry the kite but you can
see it what's interesting is that the
rhombus is actually made up of two
triangles and that's where the formula
comes from it looks a lot like
1/2 base times height right okay so
let's go ahead and look at the next
example before I do that I just want to
mention if you're preparing for the acct
check out my AC T video course is
specifically designed for the math
section it's got 21 different concept
areas in there that are covered on the
AC T that will help you to you know
boost your score on that test
so go ahead and check that out let's
look at the last example last one here
we're gonna find the area of this
rhombus notice all four sides are
congruent so we know it's a rhombus you
can see the diagonals are perpendicular
and the formula is the same it's going
to be one half diagonal 1 times diagonal
2 but in this case hmm they give us the
side lengths but they don't give us the
diagonal well we can see that this is a
30-60-90 triangle one of our special
right triangles if you need to review
that go ahead and check out the video I
did on special right triangles but if
this side is 6 okay according to special
right triangles this side is going to be
3 right and then this side here is going
to be 3 square root of 3 so if this is 3
this will also be 3 because the
diagonals bisect each other okay in a
rhombus and then if this is 3 square
root of 3 this will also be 3 square
root of 3 okay so if we put that all
together we have 1/2 this whole diagonal
is 6 square root of 3 and then this
whole diagonal is going to be 6 so if we
multiply that out we get 36 times 1/2 is
18 square root of 3 units squared that
gives us the exact area of the rhombus
so I hope you learned something here
about finding area of ROM eye and kites
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
and check out some of my past videos and
I'll see you in the next video I'll talk
to you soon